it increasingly is looking like all but
a foregone conclusion that failed former
president donald trump will run again
and will run again specifically because
he believes and is telling the people
around him that it is the one way that
he can avoid criminal prosecution for
the things that he has done we're going
to get in a moment to a new legal
analysis of whether donald trump is
heading to an indictment we're going to
get to that but before we get to that a
blockbuster new report from rolling
stone trump tells team he needs to be
president again to save himself
from criminal probes the former
president is planning on running for the
white house and away from the law
increasingly it is believed trump may
even announce before the november
midterms when donald trump formally
declares his 2024 candidacy he won't
just be running for another term in the
white house he'll be running away from
legal troubles possible criminal charges
and even the specter of prison time
in recent months trump has made clear to
associates with the legal protections of
occupying the obelisk that the legal
protections of occupying the oval office
are front of mind for him
for people with knowledge of the
situation tell rolling stone trump has
spoken about how when you were the
president of the united states it is
tough for politically motivated
prosecutors to get to you says one of
the sources who discussed the issue with
trump this summer he says when not if he
is president again a new republican
administration will put a stop to the
justice department investigation that he
views as the biden administration
working to hit him with criminal charges
or even put him and his people in prison
now that would be a pretty interesting
campaign platform i need this job to
stay out of prison
but
the craziest part of all of it i've said
before
trump is a symptom
but the real disease disease are the
people who give him money and who vote
for him if you just had trump and nobody
paid attention and nobody would be would
vote for him we wouldn't be in the mess
that we're in
even if trump admitted in a fundraising
email to donors i need you to donate so
i can become president because otherwise
they're going to put me in prison if he
just said it that way which is maybe
what he increasingly believes
his cult is trained to think he's smart
for committing obvious crimes and
getting away with them or
that it's all a witch hunt and people
are coming after him they're not
actually conditioned to think critically
did he do anything wrong when he called
and pressured georgia and said i need
1100 11 780 votes give me a break when
he said that stuff
it must have been because he really won
right i mean if they're just going after
him it's a witch hunt and there's a
couple of different really important
implications to this number one
he
a
a normal candidate and or a normal
country
would never have made him the nominee in
the first place if he had become the
nominee they never would have elected
him to the presidency
if they had elected him to the
presidency presidency and he did the
things he did they would have demanded
him removed in a way that
elected officials could not have ignored
25th amendment whatever impeachment and
removal
and had that happened or either way once
the first term is done
uh given the things that he did he would
have no shot whatsoever of raising money
and getting to power again that's not
the situation in the united states
situation in the united states is the
access hollywood tape making fun of
disabled reporters all the little things
that early would have just knocked him
out didn't he consolidated support he
activated the lowest of the low
information voters people who were in
many cases not even engaged in politics
before and built a movement around it
and now the test will be are they still
with them tens of millions are but he
doesn't need just tens of millions he
probably needs between 65 and 85 million
can he still get that number and can he
get it by admitting the reason that he's
running
um another aspect to this
if trump sees
2024
as the way to remain a free man and
maybe not literally free from prison but
just free from being in court for the
next 10 years of his life
it means he will do whatever he feels he
needs to do to destroy anybody who gets
in his way and that includes ron
desantis that includes greg abbott that
includes fox news which by the way we'll
talk later increasingly seems to be
setting themselves up to bail on trump
and to support desantis the cult base
won't turn on him can he build a big
enough group of gullible people to get
the again it's an estimate 65 probably
at this point it's more like 70 to 85
million votes that he would need uh what
happens with the never trumpers what
happens with the q anon crazies you've
got the trump cultists the old school
republicans the disaffected moderates
the clueless people who just follow
celebrities into politics or whatever
the case may be all questions to which
we don't yet have answers but the report
now is trump is running
he may announce even before the midterms
and he doing it and he will be doing it
because he sees it as the way to stay
out of criminal charges the next
question is is it likely that those
criminal charges are actually coming
your internet provider websites you
visit social media companies they all
follow you around online and profit from
selling your data anyone can piece
together this data about you it's quite
disturbing the solution is make yourself
anonymous with private internet access
our sponsor private internet access has
gone further than any other vpn to
demonstrate their commitment to your
privacy they don't collect or store any
data about user activity they've proven
this in court multiple times their
software is 100 percent open source so
you can see
that no data is being logged
everybody should be using a vpn for your
research on which vpn is most
trustworthy i think you'll land where i
did private internet access it's great
for streaming they have 24 7 customer
support they have a 30 day money back
guarantee if you don't love it you can
choose from ip addresses in 84 countries
and all 50 u.s states and my audience
gets 82 off so you can stay protected
for just two dollars and eleven cents a
month plus you'll get three months free
go to private internet access dot com
slash pacman the link is down below